たまがや村と呼ばれるや道皆さんはご存知だろう
山形県にある宿でここには
座敷童子が進んでいると言われている今回仕事でこのやどうかスピっている
この宿の予約は1年先まで満室である
果たして本当に
座敷童子はこの宿に
住んでいるのだろうか
熱いたここレイカえっ
いやいやや
いやいや
ねええええ
失礼します
ここがあっ
ふーん
機関車で孤独降りていっ
こんばんはその指だうっ
はいかわいい所狭しと置いてあります
お金です
で声入っ
濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃いおっおおっこれ登っちゃダメになったらコレ
なっちゃうって本当に本当にこうこれいいですけど持って a
[音楽]
やっ
あれお前がもちろんこれは仕事で来ているのである
ニコ生の夏のホラーイベントの一つで
座敷童子がいる宿からの生放送に出演させていただいた
放送中にも音は拾えてない間
明らかに変な音だしたのだ何もつけてないんですここ
僕から見て左こっちでしょ
えっ
今とん聞こえましたドンドンドンッ
本当にいろいろ起きてた
が10
本当に仕込みなしでやつ年から全くないですよまじですごい全くナイフ
すって
ラフを含み私以外の人が全員会
人になっ
1人
になりましたおいて聞かれたわけじゃないんですけど自分から一人で座敷グラセフ出る
などに生まれたいということであの今夜は一人で
ここに泊まります
安榮支配というとお仕事大江スタッフ皆さん帰った後の1人
座敷わら術奴はですねも薬子の変とかもうすげー折り紙が置いただけですよ
すごいねめちゃくちゃ置いてあるのは本当にそれ故れがちなんですけども生放送中に一
つ落ちたらしいです突然
しまう
マジで一人ちゃんこっちは言っていいのかいいのかな
[音楽]
スッキリ嫌な予感するんで読み解きます
まってまって本当に強くなってきたやばい普通にやばいやばい
虚偽がデバイスも普通にねこっちがニコ生で生放送じゃ部屋ですね
にゃがやばすぎる本当に凄いもんこことかもうで生品等告訴光ってたって言われてたん
ですね
ねもうすごいよこりゃぶーバーッっあああよああもうちょっとほんとじゃーっ
マジで俺ここで一人間本当にお宿だからここでね料理とがご飯食べたり調理もできる
っぽいです
冷蔵庫ですやったビールをんじゃんうわぁああここも意味深な部屋だなぁあった
勉強漬けっぽいのを置いてあるんですよねそこに国が追ってやらないですね
お風呂
おしゃれです
ビッ
でい
といる弾
借りています多様なこれねれんのかな本当に一人でめっちゃ怖いんだけどそれ本当に
座す気晴らしさんが喜ぶように稼がないんですけどももっとこうせますとね多いですね
この絵とか new ぐるみの和也くんだよ本当にもう寝ますね俺ごめんなさいねます
声です
あの皆さん1個勘違人少ないのは座敷わらして悪いわけじゃないんですよ
見たり聞いたりすると幸せとか幸福な違うって言われてるんでそれでも多いんですけど
実質その悪いいうでとじゃないんで
むしろ会いたいがありますこの映像の中でも一番座敷よろしくに言うと言われている
この部屋で今日は出てみたいと思います
まっ本当に子は本当に強い
やばい
ていた
本当は
スタートスポッ
はいという気で寝る準備が整いましたじゃあおやすみなさい
ここれでいいか
これで寝ます
始まってほんとこらっ
ねますね本当に
[音楽]
おやすみなさい
やばい本当にネコース e クラス e
はいと受けてここからちょっと僕の声で解説していきましょう
まあ普通には寝れませんですねすぐ
合間カチって音が聞こえました数々たちみたいなんでもこれは普通にその木造建築の
建物をとかなと思って
まあ普通にありえるぐらいの音ですでもうちょっと時間が進んで
こちら
勝ち勝ちみたいなちょっとラップ音ぽかった感じでしたね
これを結構大きかったですけどまぁこれぐらいも普通ね木造建築なら有り得ます僕の
実家もこんな感じなんですけどこようとしますそして更に時間が雪が見えます
[音楽]
はいなんか
コツンと言う餓鬼の音なんか木の床に何かが落ちたような音がしました
まあこれも切りありそうな感じではありますねもう一回来ます
はいまねカーンちょっと遠くでの音ですね
まだここらへんも心霊現象とは言えないかなという感じですだからここからです
なんかす3つくらい違う音が鳴りましたねば全然
ほとんどね種類が違いすぎるんですけども最後の1個はもう何かばちばちっというか
なんていうのはなんかカメラの[ __ ]合みたいな音がなってましたね
すいませんこれは本当に意味がわからないです超田舎なんでそんな車とかめっちゃとる
わけでもないしトラックが走るわけでもないんで本当に謎でしたよ
2連続で音が鳴りましたねちょっとこれくらい多い頻度だとちょっと怪しかったですね
もうちょっと色んな音がなっていきます
ちょっとさすがに年顔となりすぎてほぼ寝てたんですけどもなんか体が反応しちゃって
ましたね
ただ意識はないです
はいこの頭はマジでリーがわかりませんあのエアー公務をつけてないし
扇風機しかないんでここにそういうポチャンとかなそういう水の音がなる可能性って
ほんとゼロなんですよ
これだけは本当に不思議でした
第ボートがデカくなってきています
そしてここでいびきをかいております完全に寝ました
こっから更に時間が過ぎていきますねいやーなんか最初の方の音は本当にアディたん
ですけども
後半の音とか連続スロートとか音の大きさ
あとあゆみずっぽいちゃんぴちょんみたいな音ばあの本当に意味がわからないんです
はいね事ですねあの言った覚えがありません
年間いびきかいてぐらいから何かすっごいお願いで打つようになってたんですよこれで
じゃあ全部動画も確認したんですけどもこれ以降そういう年か
パチッとか金とかどんとそういう音は全く聞こえなかったので全部早送りとさせて
いただいております本当になる最初の時だけだった
それが本当に音がなかったです
ん
[音楽]
もうこんだけ大人ってかいと鳥肌たちましたね
聞いてて
あんなデカイとならんです本当部屋中に響き渡るぐらい大きな
中詰めって言うから何かコツンってするような音がなってました
はい今回泊まった中で一番大きい音でしたにあればって店の通りだんだん朝日が昇って
きて部屋がは辛くなってきています
朝です
[音楽]
ハイあのた釜止めらの朝のなんか
お寺の音みたいな感じですねけっこう大きな音で外でなっております
[音楽]
まったく起きませんそしてもう2匹が経ってもないで6時ぐらいかしら
4日
[音楽]
big week 所
me
おはようございます
朝です
[音楽]
pou dou dou
hp